the number one reason for breakups is
not Finance infidelity it's if you do
that there's a 99% likelihood you break
up that's pretty crazy when you think
about it Paul Carrick Brunson the
world's most influential Matchmaker you
choose a weak partner not only do you
not live as long not as happy more
unhealthy but you could literally suffer
death so who you choose as the most
important decision you could make so I
have questions you ready for this
what is the state of dating it's a hell
of a problem how do you spot a
narcissist so the key is to this golden
mean thing in your book what is that
it's the optimal measure of what we
consider to be sexy po women is the
percentage of your waist to your hips so
what is the future of dating I know a
lot of people will be mad at me for this
but you go there if you want to it's
like arrange marriages data shows us
people in the range marriage have higher
satisfaction because and this is often
where many people go wrong what should
should I be looking for in a partner it
has come at 10 years of research on this
there's five key characteristics that we
need
one Paul I wanted to go over this thing
called attachment Theory because I think
I'm in avoidant attachment style I love
this topic there's some phenomenal
research looking at the number of
orgasms that people have based on their
attachment style and if they were
avoidant the data showed that no comment
Moving on but I have to say why though
this is important
quick one this is really really
fascinating to me on the back end of our
YouTube channel it says that
69.9% of you that watch this channel
frequently over the lifetime of this
channel haven't yet hit the Subscribe
button I just wanted to ask you a favor
it helps this channel so much if you
choose to subscribe helps us scale the
guest helps us scale the production and
it makes this show bigger so if I could
ask you for one favor if you've watched
the show before and you've enjoyed it
and you like this episode that you're
currently watching could you please hit
the Subscribe button thank you so much
and I will pay that gesture by making
sure that everything we do here gets
better and better and better and better
that is a promise I'm willing to make
you do we have a
[Music]
deal Paul last time I had you on my show
you were a Smash Hit And I look at the
episodes and I can see the retention of
every conversation I have the retention
is essentially how many minutes of the
conversation someone listened to you and
you're a real record breaker on our show
in terms of retention because the
message that you communicate is
communicated in such a compelling
relatable way but you're speaking to a
problem that all of us have in our lives
which is this problem of love yes and
just I I know your story but there's
there's a chance that some people that
that have just clicked this don't know
your
story the wisdom you have what is the
experience that you've been on and how
long is that experience and what's the
sort of flavor and diversity of that
experience that has has culminated in
this wisdom you have about relationship
science what have you been exposed to
and how long for I spent my first part
of my career in finance so I was a
researcher in Investment Banking I went
off got my business degree you know so I
I was on that track and then I switched
the track to focus on relationship
science and then in the process of
switching I had an opportunity to work
for two incredible people two
billionaires so in the Rel on the
finance side it was a gentleman by the
name of Enver yuo who's a billionaire
out of turkey and owns the largest
for-profit education company in the
world and then when I switched into
relationship science I had an
opportunity of working for Oprah Winfrey
right and so these were two billionaires
and I say billionaires I underscore that
because they were two entirely different
people different characteristics
different uh setups at home but yet they
had the same behaviors and I started to
write about those beh behaviors and by
writing about those behaviors I ended up
becoming a journalist for USA Today my
wife and I launched what was considered
to be the largest matchmaking business
in the United States and then we sold
that in 2017 and that's what ended up
allowing us to come to the UK but the
heart of what I do is I I'm the world's
biggest nerd when it comes to
relationship science I I wake up every
morning I'm reading some bit of research
I'm going to sleep every night falling
asleep uh on some lecture around
relationship science I I think it's it's
one of the most
undervalued areas and the decisions that
we make around relationships are have
dramatic dramatic impact on how we show
up what happens in our lives what
happens to the lives of those around us
and what happens to the Lives who come
after us our children so these are very
important decisions and I think that's
the reason why it occupies so much of my
thought have you been exposed to any
first party data I know that you I think
maybe was it Tinder have shown you some
data yeah absolutely last year I became
the head of global insights for Tinder
and what that has allowed me to do is
see quite honestly more data on dating
that gives me more insight than I think
I'd say a lot of people in the world uh
i h i co-wrote a a report this year
called the future of dating 2023 uh that
looks at behavior on the app and also
Behavior around the world and I made
some projections in there j z is going
to have the
strongest strong the strongest marriages
ever which which a lot of look see face
everyone's like what yeah so so I made
some bold predictions in there um but uh
but but but but absolutely T Tinder that
partnership has allowed me some great
insights what is the state of dating
what is the future of dating in your
view I want to know like where we are as
a as a people and also I guess
understanding where we are we have to
understand where we've come from and
then from there we can understand where
we're going I guess yes yeah let's look
back okay so we you know humans 300,000
years ago right started there was no
dating it was more so what was called
assortative mating which was the
selection of other people based on
similar characteristics so we would look
at someone and say okay you behave
similar to how I behave you look kind of
like how I look therefore we will mate
and the whole objective was procreation
that was it in hunter gatherer days and
you can take that all the way up into
almost the
1800s so Eli finle is a great researcher
out of New York and he wrote one of my
favorite books the all Oro marriage and
he calls that entire phase the pragmatic
phase you were making a a a selection
based on the fact that you wanted to
live next week right that that was that
was why you chose a partner or or or the
procreation of it but then between the
1800s and the 1960s is what Eli fle
calls the Romantic Period this is the
period where we began to say okay hold
on for a second the Industrial
Revolution is happening we're moving
into more nuclear family so we're moving
away from our Clans if you will and
therefore I'm lonely I don't have my
cousins around me anymore I'm working in
this job all day this Factory all day so
this partner of mine who for L was all
about pretty much just my sex partner
now is going to become my friend so this
romantic age is where you see
companionship rise but still in that
phase you're still not receiving all of
your value all of all of what you love
about a partner is not coming from just
the partner or should I say all of what
you need in life is not coming from your
partner your intellectual stimulation is
coming from someone down the street
right you have friends at work that you
use For Your Entertainment and joy but
your partner is beginning to become your
companion and that's the second phase
right that that's the second phase is
the Romantic phase and then in 1960 what
you see happening and this is in Western
Society is you see what the pill is
created you see the uh the the the the
the washing machine is created and these
inst these these tools if you will begin
to free women right we're still living
in a patriarchy hands down but in the
1960s you began to see women For the
First Time begin to have a little bit of
decision a little bit of choice in who
they chose as a partner and from the
1960s on you have what Eli fle calls the
age of
self-expression now the reason why this
is so important for us today is because
what ends up happening is now you move
forward to today what do we want well we
want the highest level of well-being as
maslo would say you think about maso's
hierarchy of needs at the bottom is you
just want food you just want shelter you
just want to be safe but as you get
those things you go higher and higher to
the pyramid and the top of the pyramid
is
self-actualization and this is what most
of us want because most of us are living
in a state of privilege we have water we
have food we have shelter so we want to
be our best selves we want to flourish
as Aristotle said we want to flourish so
if we want to flourish now then we need
a partner who can help us flourish it's
no longer about the 1800s or the 1,000
where you just needed a partner to to
you know basically have sex with and
make sure they could you know protect
you like we're we're gone from that we
now we want self-expression and if we
want self-expression we have different
demands on our partner and that means
dating is now more complicated than it
has ever been everybody thinks they want
Choice men and women we all think we
want choice but I I'm quite fascinated
by the psychology of choice and how it
can result in indecision but also
valuing what you've chosen less or more
and that's sort of context dependent I
think here about arranged marriages and
you talk about that in the book and what
we can learn from arranged marriages
because
you know that's a situation where you're
given very little Choice yes yeah so
what happens there yeah this is a
controversial one in in the book and I
know a lot of people are going be mad at
me for this but here's what the data
tells us that arranged marriages on
average last longer and both and both
people in the arranged marriage have
higher
satisfaction now I will also say a lot
of people people are entering arranged
marriages with no decision a lot of
arranged marriages um are happening
where I would say are aoral right
however let's look at why it could be
because I think that's the beauty of
empirical evidence of research is it
allows you to think about the
possibilities of why and what what can
we learn from this one of the reasons
why is because when we think we're in
love most of us are not most of us are
in this blind state of limerance where
we are infatuated with the person in
front of us and we really know nothing
about them and we know nothing about
decision-making and we don't fully trust
them the sex is good right and we say
Okay I want to spend the rest of my life
with this person right what's happening
in most arranged marriages is you have a
village you have multiple people in your
sphere could be parents brothers sisters
friends who have your best interest and
they sit and they cohesively decide is
this the right partner for you and
they're looking at behaviors that you
may not be able to see you know I saw
this with my matchmaking agency in the
matchmaking agency the first thing that
we would do when a client would come in
is I would
interview friends and family co-workers
colleagues people you report to people
who report to you previous girlfriends
you know love interests and with that I
would look for the consensus and and I
would I would use all of that to say
okay this is who Steven is he comes in
and he tells me this is who he is but I
talk to all of these people in his spere
and I understand this is who he is and
the reason why we have a hard time
understanding who we are is because of
cognitive dissonance right we believe as
human beings we think that we behave
behave as we think we behave but we
actually don't like we we don't what we
say we value chances are we don't really
value that you know in matchmaking again
I would ask what are your values and
then they would give me this long list
oh you know I'm I'm a Christian uh and I
uh Value Health and right so this is
what you do and then two days later I'd
say okay last Saturday when you off work
what did you do with your time oh I went
out and I pigged out I ate all day and
then I went to this concert and I did
this and I said well where was church in
that where was Bible study where was
this and what I've noticed is that where
we spend that free time where we spend
our discretionary
money that's what we value so true I've
thought a lot about this recently about
how what I say should be reflected in
how my calendar looks yes and that is
the true sort of evidence of me living
my values and really what I do value and
I think people struggle with this
sometimes because what they'll say and
rebuttal to that is well I'm just so
busy Paul I'm so so busy I've got kids
I've got you know mortgage to pay Etc I
have to say they are entirely right that
we have a finite amount of time but in
that they're showing what they value
they are showing that they value their
kids and their life yes their ability to
live and eat that is a value that is a
priority and this is also why I think
our values should be viewed in
especially as it relates to to like how
we allocate our time as a as a list of
priorities I this is most important then
this then this then this then this
because we can value 20 things it
doesn't mean we're going to do them
because we you know time is finite but
values aren't necessarily they they're
not I completely agree it it it should
be a level of prioritization right and
we should own we should comfortably own
what that is yes so if it is time with
your children then you value that you
know that's what you value stand by that
because the more that you can stand by
that and erect boundaries around that
the happier you'll be the more fulfilled
you'll be and you you can spot it in the
language because if if I embodied what
you just said when someone asks Steve
why haven't you gone to the gym my
response would would
be I had other
priorities it wouldn't be I can't right
you know I couldn't or it wouldn't be
blame it wouldn't be excuses it would
literally be the the recognition that
there was other priorities that won and
that is okay okay that is okay but it's
so interesting so arranged marriages
people in arranged marriages report high
levels of satisfaction and stay together
longer yeah on on on average and and and
and even to to break that down a bit
right is you have the the family making
the decision right so the family is able
to see things that you may not be able
to see so that's that's that's one big
driver of it the second driver of it is
let's look at traditional marriage now
out outside of arranged marriages right
now and this is Eli finle research 80%
of current marriages are more
dissatisfied than they ever have been
ever and 20% are more satisfied than
they than they ever have been now now
why is that it's because of what we were
talking about previously and that is is
that we now want so much more from our
partner we we want our partner to be our
best friend our lover our
co-ceo our running buddy our you
therapist our therapist right spiritual
leader spiritual leader our Netflix and
chill buddy like we we want all of this
now out of our partner and so what many
people are recognizing is they're waking
up they're saying you know I can only
get like 50% from from my partner of
what I want or 60% and many people are
not satisfied as a result of that but
the 20% are looking at their partner
they're using all of these available
tools we have we have so much incredible
data around how to have a successful
relationship that if you are putting in
the work and your partner is putting in
the work you can be more satisfied than
ever right and so that's the reason why
a small percentage are more satisfied so
part of the reason why that group is
more satisfied than the average is
because the average is not satisfied so
if you're in that that sort of 80% of
unsatisfied people in their
relationships is one solution to that to
encourage or facilitate your partner in
meeting their needs in other places and
I say this because my partner lived in
barley for two years and then I was
living here so there was this
long-distance relationship where there
was we wouldn't see each other sometimes
for 60 days for two months especially
with the lockdowns and all that stuff it
was crazy and then we got to that point
in our relationship where we realized
that one of us has to move if this
relationship is going to going to work
so do she move to bar to London from
Bary or do I move my life to Bary okay
which is super difficult was it pretty
hard yeah yeah yeah I quit dragging down
I st the podcast it's like my business
is I forget All for Love yeah but I I
knew that I could never ask her to to
move here I could never do that she had
to make that decision for herself
because I've seen scenarios where
there's resentment and all of these
things and contempt when you move you
you it's almost like you take on the
responsibility of that person if you if
you tell them to come to your to your
neck of the woods yeah and one of the
first things I thought about
was I'm a busy person and if she doesn't
have a friendship group here a purpose
here work here then I'm going to be have
to be the source of all of those things
yes and that's terrifying yes and I tell
you for the first part of our
relationship when she'd moved here
I felt like I did have to be those
things once she started her business
here and her with her business came a
community and it came her whole little
tribe and her own sense of purpose and I
look over in the kitchen when I come
back from work and she's on the laptop
in the corner obsessed with her work and
I thought God yeah yeah like yeah but
that's what it must have would have been
like back in the day when you were
talking about phase two of the history
of relationships oh oh yeah I mean that
that's that's the reason why it's it's
interesting why I mean to to to that
original question of yours is that we
are in such a complicated state right
now because we all have different goals
you know maybe in your relationship you
know it it it it already sounds that you
and your girlfriend are interested in
self-actualization right you you want to
flourish yeah you know of course you
want to flourish but some people may not
want to flourish if you go down maso's
hierarchy of needs for some folks it's
just about belonging or it could be just
about self-esteem or it could be just
the safety I just know I have someone
with me just the safety so we so we have
these different needs and I think that's
why one of the most important things we
can do for ourselves is to identify what
is it that we want out of this world and
then
unapologetically go after it surround
yourself with people who are going after
it romantically professionally socially
you know find your tribe uh and that's
where you'll thrive on that point as
well you said about friends knowing you
better than you know yourself and kind
of by way of that knowing maybe what you
should be going for mhm how important
you think it is to listen to your
friends when they tell you that this
ain't the one he ain't the guy oh I had
a conversation recently with a friend
who I Shan name who you know we're all
saying to this person listen this ain't
the guy and you can see this that
Absolut the point is absolutely not
Landing you must have seen this a
million times all the time all the time
all the time if all of your friends are
saying this ain't the guy this ain't the
guy no matter what it will not work out
100% of the times it it it it won't the
the the friend the I think there's
certain things that we did with this
matchmaking agency that I really think
were groundbreaking that was one if you
can look at what your friends and family
and all of the people who love you are
saying and they all say the same thing
that's the
truth and how important is it to get
your [__] together before you go into a
relationship I've always wondered this
I've wondered do you go into a
relationship in the situation fixes you
or do you fix yourself then go into the
relationship you talk about this in the
book the idea that our satisfaction
levels in a relationship will vary based
on our satisfaction levels before the
relationship yes so this was one of the
most enlightening I think pieces of what
we're not hearing what we hear in pop
culture all the time is if you have
shared values that's what makes the
strongest marriage or that's what makes
the strongest relationship some people
say if you have great sex that's what
makes the strongest relationship but
actually what what we found in the
research here is if you walk into a
relationship and you have a high level
of satisfaction that is what gives you
the highest level of satisfaction in the
relationship so the key is you want to
figure out how you could flourish you
know on your own on your own Carol riff
is one of the people who I don't think
she gets enough attention out here in
the relationship science space or even
in the world right she's a brilliant res
Searcher and in the 1980s she sat down
and she looked at every theorist who's
written about flourishing and then she
figures out the consensus what are all
of these great theorists saying about
flourishing and well-being and she
created what's called The Six Dimensions
of psychological well-being and I never
hear anyone talk about this it's like
the mo one of the most important
Concepts ever for us and what she's
outlined is that there's six areas that
we should be focused on if we want to
flourish with or without a partner one
of them is personal development are you
on the path to personal growth are you
doing things to develop yourself right
number two do you have inspiration do
you have a goal that you are Marching
towards in life number three is autonomy
feeling like you have control over your
time next one number four is what's
called environmental mastery
this is do you feel like the area that
you're in physically the area that
you're in the city that you may live in
the town that you may live in is it
conducive to you doing all the things
that you want to do right in life next
is having a strong relationship with
other people whether it be romantically
it could it could be platonically but do
you feel like you have connections do do
you have friends right and last but not
least is a concept that she calls self
acceptance this is very important
self-acceptance is knowing the demons
that you have inside and being okay with
them it's it's it's knowing and
acknowledging that you know I'm good but
I do have some bad and I accept my bad
if you are working towards all of those
things all of those six dimensions you
will have the highest level of
well-being you'll reach
self-actualization and to your question
this is something that we should be
doing with or without a partner and if
you could do it without a partner when
you enter your partnership it will be
that much stronger people that you've
spoken to that are struggling in their
relationships do you think they have
this opinion that the relationship is
going to fix their problems yes yeah I I
I think we walk into relationships and
we think it's the end we think that's
check
done it's not it's it's it's where the
work begins
and we have to change this and a lot of
this has to do with and you know and I
put some of the blame on me you know I
think some of this is television you
know some of this is is is is the you
know a lot of people call it the
disneyfication you know of of
relationships uh
we misunderstand and misinterpret our
role in
relationships how I I fundamentally
believe that the number one reason for
breakups is not we we hear reports all
the time that it's Finance it's
infidelity it's no it's none of those
things you know what it is it's we pick
bad Partners we select the wrong
Partners or we don't make the selection
at all many of us and unfortunately I
see this a I see this a lot with
heterosexual women is they allow
themselves to be selected opposed to
making this Choice themselves so so so
the first part is is are we choosing the
strongest partners for us that's one and
then once we have chosen the partner
then are we working together to help our
partner unveil their best self you know
the Michelangelo effect and Eli finle
writes about this where you know
Michelangelo would never look at a stone
and say I'm going to carve this
beautiful statue instead he'd look at
the stone and say I'm going to unveil
this beautiful piece of art this
beautiful statue that's in the stone
that's how we should look at our partner
is that we all have this beautiful
statue within us and when you find the
strongest partner that allows you to see
that you know I know you've had Dr
waldinger on Phenom like he says it in
in his research you live longer you're
happier you make more money you know you
get all of the benefits When you choose
a strong partner but if you choose lose
a weak partner not only do you not live
as long not only are you not as happy
not only are you more unhealthy but but
you can literally suffer not just
emotional and psychological distress
there is a rise of domestic violence
that is happening in our in these
relationships around the world so you
could literally suffer death death by
choosing the wrong partner and so it
goes to show how important the decision
is this this is this is a life or death
decision I want to go into all of those
things you said about selecting
selecting poorly and the life and death
the life and death decision that comes
with Psychopaths and narcissists and all
that stuff um you know what's
interesting is when you say to me that
the work starts at the relationship
there's part of me that
goes do you know what I mean cuz in the
movies I was thinking of all these
movies I scene in New York where there's
a Twist there's a turn and then there's
a happily ever after and the movie ends
and and you think when the movie ends in
all of these movies that we've watched
for 10 20 30 years you think that is the
end you think they live happily ever
after I watched the turmoil I watched
the battle and then they live happily
ever after if that movie was to be
extended any movie we've seen romantic
movie what you'd then see is another 30
years of like [__] but we don't see
that so I was just thinking like where
did we get this idea from that the work
stops when we find the person yeah it's
it's it's it's coming so it's coming
from a couple places one is that's where
it did stop at one point you think about
the pragmatic stage the Romantic stage
that was all you needed you just needed
the partner it didn't matter you didn't
have to do any work with the partner so
so we we have gotten this honestly as a
as a society but also it's what pop
culture it's what media it's it's it's
what it feeds us but I would would say
don't look at it as hard distasteful
work yeah instead here's a better way
let's reframe it reframe the negative
right is this podcast right
credible one skill you're probably
learning incredible skills doing this
one of which I'm sure is your active
listening is off the charts now compared
to what it maybe was day one now if you
thought active listening I'm going to
learn active listening during this
podcast did you think then it would be
grueling I don't think so I think that
you probably saw that as a great life
skill I can come in here I'm going to
not only meet all I'm going to do all
this incredible things but I'm also
going to develop skills and these skills
are transferable to everything I do
that's how we should look at our
relationship look at it that way you are
going to learn incredible skills that
are transferable across your life and as
you develop those skills the whole Tide
Rises you're going to to uh develop new
skills and and and better Master new
skills and then apply those to your
business apply those to to your platonic
relationship so it it's it's it's a
wonderful thing
and when you are in a secure
relationship it's boring as
hell it's boring which is why you know
uh not to get myself into trouble but
you know when you're watching television
and you're watching these shows around
relationships uh actually I I'll give an
examp I will give an example um when I
got here to the UK uh I started on a on
a show called slubs go dating and then I
very quickly went to a show called
Married at First Sight UK and when I was
on Married at First Sight UK my first
series it was a full docu series and we
matched couples and it was boring you
know why it was boring because they all
loved each other they all really liked
each other other and out of that group
of four couples three of them are
together today wow right but you ask
anyone in the UK did you see that series
they'll say no we didn't say that
because it's boring and then you change
things and you get couples who can still
work but there's tension right for a
variety of reasons there's tension and
then it gets exciting and so one thing
that I always say is great love look
looks boring but it feels great you know
good love it it feels it it good love
looks boring but it feels great
menh men are struggling it seems I think
you know the more and more I talk on
this show about dating apps and what
it's like to be a man in this dating
climate especially one that's become
more digitalized than ever before the
conversation always emerges in the in
the in the com sort of like the comment
sections and stuff about men's struggles
here because you know these dating apps
they seem to
be not welld designed for the like
bottom 50% of menh what is what what are
your thoughts on this yeah I'm I'm I'm
with you you know what I like about the
conversation today is we're finally
acknowledg it's it's it's okay to
acknowledge that you know men are
getting crapped on you know I I feel
like just a year ago if you said that oh
no what are you talking about you know
we're still in the patriarchy you can't
no men are struggling High suicide rates
highest levels of loneliness highest
issues around mental health men are
struggling and the fact that we can just
ex talk about that and all acknowledge
okay let's figure out how to deal with
this is a good place to begin right but
but but now we now we have to begin you
know it begins with the awareness and
talking about it it extends into
creating safe spaces
for men to be able to talk I love that
what you see now is you see these
podcast
communities um creating these spaces
where men feel like they can be
acknowledged and seen and that allows
for there to be connection with other
men going through those same challenges
which creates camaraderie and helps you
to uh to to break out of that loneliness
so so so we're we're we're on the path
uh but we have to acknowledge some of
those larger trends that we see I know
Richard Reeves uh talks about this quite
a bit phenomenal book of boys and men
where you can see uh just the levels of
unemployment the lower levels of
educational attainment uh for for men
the high levels of uh of drug usage the
high levels of what uh Richard Reeves
calls sedation essentially is uh drug
usage uh pornography watching where uh
you have a large number of men men just
sedating themselves out of pain right
out of loneliness and so I I think we're
in a great place to begin working on the
problem but it's a hell of a problem in
your book on uh page 72 it says that in
the Tinder research you found that one
of the main reasons men aren't in
relationships is because of rejection
yes fear of rejection yes number one and
and many people would laugh at that they
would laugh at that stat what men walk
up to me all the time so how is it that
men are fearful of rejection but the
fact of the matter is that the majority
of men report the number one reason why
they believe they can't find a
significant other is the fear of being
rejected think about that and that's not
just in person that's online feeling as
if you are going to deny me you're going
to reject me and to me that speaks to
self-esteem to me that speaks to
self-love to me that speaks to selfworth
and so therefore we have to really
evaluate the the the why the the why why
is that you know but I I think this is
such an important point and this is why
we have to look back let's look at
history why is it the case that the
Calvin Klein model or why is it the case
that the higher status person gets more
interaction if you think back to
pragmatic right if you were a
woman what did you need to
survive uh I needed a mate that would
protect me exactly now the protection
would come in one of two things and I
say that because at some point I'm going
to be eight and a half months pregnant
and I I ain't going to be able to hunt
no you know or forage or I don't know
exactly and so so you need to have the
protection and the protection came in in
one of two ways one physicality right
right someone's just strong and fight
but the other was high social status
resources which would bring resources
which would bring resources and
therefore you know you'd have the
protection because of that so how long
did that
continue yeah most of human history most
of human history so we have through
Evolution this has been indoctrinated
into our into our system and what is
rarely talked about is so you know there
were millions of men throughout history
who were not the Calvin Klein not the
biggest didn't have the social status so
what happened to them in history do you
know what happened to them most of them
they were the ones sent to
war these were the men fighting for
whatever country the the these were the
men when you when you watch Napoleon and
you see oh my God the Battle of waterl
you had tens of thousands of people
who's dying it's those men it's not the
high stat status men it's not it's not
the Calvin Klein looking right it's
those men we're dying and we've reached
a point in society where we're no longer
fighting Wars like that we're fighting
with drones and missiles you have
millions upon Millions upon millions of
men sitting there saying okay now what
about me what about me and this is the
problem this is where we are what about
men what were they selecting
for they were selecting for youth
fertility fertility y they they wanted
youth which which spoke to
fertility uh and that ran through time
and that's the reason why you see a
woman who you know I talk about this in
the book there's this golden mean golden
mean I read this and it was the first
time I'd ever heard of this idea of the
golden mean but it was super interesting
the golden mean explained why my
girlfriend seems to like my shoulders
she doesn't care if I get fat I swear to
you I asked her one day I was like what
do you prefer cuz she asked me she said
what features do you prefer on me and
obviously I knew that was a trap so I
said
everything I'm not stupid but then when
she asked the question she I asked her
the question back I was like what what
features do you prefer on me she was
like your shoulders yeah and I was like
really I was like I thought they said
you wanted like I thought women wanted a
six-pack she was like she was holding my
shoulders she was like your shoulders
yes and then I read this golden mean
thing in your book and I was like ah
yeah yeah that's that's how I I I could
you know what's interesting I spot
everyone and I almost am calculating
golden mean because I'm always thinking
as a Matchmaker like I can match that so
the the golden mean has stood throughout
history and there's a different
calculation for for men and women for
women the calculation is the difference
between waist and hips right so it's the
percentage of your waist to your hips so
if on average your waist is
70% of what your hips are that is
considered to be
fertile right you're considered to be at
optimal you know your op optimal for
Fertilization in in in essence and you
could see that ratio tested throughout
time and you could see that ratio tested
throughout culture which is rare to go
to an Eastern collectivist society and
see something similar to what's
happening in a western uh
individualistic society and so the
golden mean stands through time and the
reason why it's so interesting is
because you look at like Twiggy in the
1970s I think uh in the UK you say gosh
Twiggy was so thin but she still had a
70% golden mean you you look at the you
know people talk about the the Kim
Kardashians of the world she has less
than 70% she's probably like 50% right
golden mean and so the golden mean is
the optimal measure of what we just
consider to be fertile therefore sexy on
average and so that hasn't been
influenced by you know magazines and
media and stuff like that that's just
what scientists think that's in eight
hum yes they think that that's inate but
it is it is impacted by culture so you
go into different subcultures and there
might be more of an exaggeration of the
golden mean right so maybe it's more
than 70% or should I say less than 70%
could be what's considered more
attractive so it is influenced but on
average that is it and the reason why I
say that is it is because uh many men
would argue oh no you'll say what what
are you are you you're you're a breast
man you're a leg man like what what what
is it like it's a Thanksgiving dinner
you know what I mean and uh those could
be characteristics and features that you
find sexy and attractive but on average
this is what will um what will light up
most most men and then for me for for
women when they're looking at a a man
the golden mean is the difference
between shoulders and waist and so if
you have if your waist is 70% or less
than your shoulders then that is
considered to be what someone who could
protect me that's where that comes from
you know and therefore throughout
hundreds of thousands of years of of of
of of History we get to the point where
okay it's sexy why is it sexy I don't
know you just look sexy no the reason
why it look sexy is because ultimately
back in the day he could have been a
protector so that's where that comes
from and in the matchmaking Community
what I used to do all the time is if I
had a client who was you know say a male
client and he didn't really represent
the the golden mean I'd say put on this
this this uh this this Blazer here you
know wide shoulder pad Blazer go out
there on that date um you know so the
golden mean is something that has stood
the test of time so many people are
going to be doing like shoulder
pressing tonight that's crazy that's all
you need to do yeah a little bit of
shoulder press that's it that's so crazy
um but it but it makes evolutionary
sense that there
is is it proportions the right word that
we would associate with fertility or you
know
protection what's this concept in
chapter 4 you talk about the concept of
mate value uh yeah this is this is I
feel like the whole now it's
controversial this this give a quick
disclaimer this is a another topic that
a lot of people want to push back on
right mate value is a
evolutionary
psychology term that is around
technically what value do we bring to
the mating Marketplace because when you
think about uh you know our evolution is
that we go on one or two paths in mating
we call it dating evolutionary they're
calling it mating long-term mating or
short-term mating right now short-term
mating is a separate Beast short-term
mating is literally I want to have sex
tonight therefore you're going to look
at different characteristics you're not
going to care if you can trust the
person you're not going to care like
you're going to look at what they look
like and that really might not mean
anything to you that's short-term ating
long-term mating is much different
long-term mating is just okay I'm
looking for a partner for life and part
of the calculation that we're doing
innately the calculation that we're
doing is what do we value the person
it's no different than someone saying oh
yeah he's a he's a nine or or or she
she's a 10 you know 10 out of 10 she's a
10 in essence that's what mate value is
but I look at mate value as all of the
ingredients that we bring to the table
so yes it is about physically how we
look it is about status in our job yeah
that's important but it's also about how
kind we are it's also about our Behavior
it's also about how confident we are
when when we walk into a room all of
these pieces add up to mate value but
the reason why I say it's it's so
important to know is because mate value
will also change based on the
context for example if I take so I keep
you're going to be my reference here if
if if I take you Stephen and I bring you
to Richmond Virginia where my wife is
from and we go to a restaurant you walk
in everyone is mesmerized by you the
moment you open your mouth amazing
everyone is where is it
rich what a post
code
Richmond a note here um everyone is the
moment the moment that you speak wow
I've never heard an accent like that
tell me more about you right they're
intrigued it's what I call the premium
effect that lands on top of the mate
value right but we have to understand
that there is a value that we assign
people when we are mating or dating you
conveniently skipped over the one about
having kids oh yeah yeah yeah no no but
so having kids it goes up or it it
brings your value up or it brings your
value down now it depends on what your
partner is seeking so if you if if you
if CH so chances are let's say that you
are a woman uh you have
children and you are uh you're you're
dating a a man who does not yet have
children and wants to have children
chances are that is going to lower in
his eyes on average that's going to
lower the that's going to lower your
perceived mate value however however if
he has children or maybe he's a little
bit older or may what for for whatever
the reason he could look at that as as
as as an upside the point there though
is that it's the context that changes
your mate value and that's very
important the context is what changes it
so this premium effect you talked about
then when you talking about um Richmond
Virginia how can one use that to
increase my chance of finding someone to
fall in love with and just just give a
bit of color on what you mean by the
premium effect is it being a scarce
commodity in a certain environment yeah
that's exactly or a desirable commodity
in a certain environment it it's being
scarce scarce okay yeah so when we
started the matchmaking agency it was
focused exclusively for black women and
the reason why is because I felt as if
black women were being highly
discriminated against in the matchmaking
space and so I was trying everything and
so I thought you know what I'm going to
do I'm going to start putting my clients
on dating apps and I will act as them
and I saw that they were not getting
traction is that statistically
proven I'd love to know yeah you know I
will say from all of my experience in
matchmaking it was that black women got
less matches on dating apps less swipes
it it in in my time when I was running
that dating agency absolutely absolutely
hands like hands down there there there
was no question why well you know
there's lots of reasons one reason is
that when it comes to outside of gen Z
so if you look at Millennials you look
at Gen X you look at baby boomers and at
that time gen Z wasn't yet on dating
apps we're talking about Millennials and
higher we typically choose
ethnicity over every other category
so ethnicity ended up being one of the
first selections of a partner and we
would either bring you you know we would
either include you or exclude you based
on ethnicity jenz has changed this and
I'm and I'm so happy to see this gen Z
is the first generation to at majority
have interest in everyone so on Tinder
for example we see that 80% of our gen Z
they are not just open but they have
dated someone outside of their ethnicity
and I believe that we're entering this
new phase of what I call we are we are
inter everything we are inter ethnic
International
interreligious that to me is is is
beautiful but that didn't happen for
Millennials it definitely didn't happen
for Gen X and definitely not for baby
boomer so ethnicity was number one so
because of that and because of the pools
of uh black men on dating apps of that
age range were so much smaller that you
saw a very small selection rate for
black women so that's what was driving
the low low low perceived interest but
what I didn't like what was happening is
you would see this data come out uh you
know black women are not selected or not
swiped on or whatever it may be and it
would be projected as black women are
not design
which is like the most ridiculous thing
in the world I like what are you talking
about but the reason why is because they
were taking these small data sets and
essentially claiming this larger
narrative based on this small data set
and so when I was experimenting with
those uh W with with my clients I then
said okay what would happen if I put my
black female clients onto J date
right Jewish date you know and they were
not Jewish like they were Ultra
Christian right what would happen so I
started putting them on J date
phenomenal success
like phenomenal success phenomenal
success there was a percentage of people
who responded who were crude why are you
here there was a percentage of people
who responded who were obviously
fetishizing oh I want to do this to you
right but then there was a percentage of
people who were just curious let's see
why did you that's interesting you're
why are you here like let's let's have
this conversation and the
interactions were
plentiful and what I realized there is
there was a premium effect being
assigned there was a extra value that
they got by being the scarce commodity
in in this space and so my objective
with a lot of my clients was to take
them and put them in places where they
are few that's so interesting and and we
can do that IRL as well we can put
ourselves in situations where we're
scarce in real life is it going to like
a different type of sports club or you
know what what what is that yeah so I um
I I try this out here I have a friend
who lives in hartfordshire she is a
white woman friend 30
mid-30s uh completely open to meeting
everyone right she's like Paul I'm
single I don't know what to do I said
all right here here's what you do come
on down to South London I want you to go
to this exhibit that's happening at the
black cultural archives in
Brixton and I want you to go down there
and you just tell me what happened she
went down she was like oh my God it was
crazy I met blah blah blah blah blah and
and and and the point was that she put
herself in a place where she was a quote
unquote scarce commodity if you if you
want to look at it in economic terms
which I like you know that's exactly
what she did and she met incredible
people now did she have romantic uh
connection there no but she walked out
of there with two friends that she's
kept in touch with you know for a year
plus so think about where your interests
lie but where you can step out and be
different where you could be unique you
can do that in every aspect of your life
but you know what the underlying driver
is to being able to do that is
self-esteem because the higher
self-esteem you have the less external
validation you need less you need to
conform to the environment exactly even
there's some great studies that show
that the higher self-esteem you have the
less you need to have someone who's
traditionally
attractive interesting yeah because you
start to see all of the value all all
the beautiful nature and behaviors of
and physicality of someone and you don't
need to walk down the street and have
everyone say he looks like he he's so
beautiful or she's so beautiful you know
you have value in that person so
therefore you know and and so high
self-esteem is indicative of so many
aspects of our life and you could show
up get that premium effect if you have
high self-esteem I've never heard anyone
talk about this before because and that
is so interesting because I I was every
time I hear an idea I think we all at
home everyone listening to this will
kind of sense check the concept on like
friends they know and people they know
and I and I would say that of all of my
of everybody I know the people that are
typically lower self-esteem are those
that are most focused on appearances and
looks in fact there's one of my friends
who when he he called me one day in the
gym and said I'm not sure about his
current partner um and I like why what's
up he goes you know like when I walk
into a restaurant with her on my arm I
just don't know how it looks literally
that's what he to me and I remember
having the convers with him like BR you
are screwed if that's what you're
judging this individual based on how
they look on your arm yes but it's a but
it's a consequence of his own need for
validation from the person he's with and
and then it's no surprise that the other
correlation you see is those people are
probably still single those are my still
friends that are still single the ones
that care the most about that that can
currently have the most the lowest
self-esteem are also the ones that are
still missing probably great people for
looking at the wrong things there you go
that that's why we need to be in a state
of flourishing ourselves before you go
out there because because think if if he
was able to just take a breather work on
his self-esteem fact there's so many
things you could do boost your
self-esteem think of how incredible his
next relationship would be facts yeah
yeah self-esteem is is really where it's
at like it's it's underrated that's so
interesting this idea that when we have
low self-esteem will care more about how
the person looks because they
are we believe that they can boost our
self-esteem by just being next to them
that's crazy yeah and well more so we
believe that Society accepts them and we
won't be shamed by society as a result
of being with them right because we want
the validation from society when we have
low self-esteem but if you have high
self-esteem you you know what this is my
partner and I don't care what you think
it doesn't matter what you think I'm
happy then you can walk down the street
with
anyone and if you encountered in your
work as a Matchmaker back in the day
someone who was low
self-esteem what would you suggest them
to do would it would it be therapy would
was there something small they could do
in their life a first step they could
take yeah I mean so so what we would do
with the agency is we would not even
start matchmaking them until we went
through months and months and months of
coaching right now what are some things
that you could do practical things you
could do it's about practicing
self-compassion is a great way to boost
self-esteem so that could be journaling
that could be meditating that could be
exercising it also is about setting
goals achievable goals and accomplishing
those goals that helps to boost your
self-esteem on the pathway to mastering
something boosts self esteem for example
during lockdown I started learning the
the piano right just started learning it
and once I got to phase two of my little
piano you know at home tutorial I got a
little boost of okay I can do a little
thing and then I played uh wuang Clan
casuals everything around me I did cream
on my piano and just doing
that boost self-esteem right so the
Mastery of something
small self-compassion surrounding
yourself with other people who have
self-esteem High self-esteem these are
some basic ways to help to boost it I I
was thinking a lot about this and I said
um I said to one of my friends the other
day about this idea of keeping
commitments to yourself and I think I
was talking about it with Chris
Williamson as well about the commitments
we keep to ourselves when no one is
watching feed into our self-image like I
think some of us think that self-esteem
is what we've like accomplished in Life
or what we haven't accomplished in life
but if we narrow it right down and zoom
right into like this morning I told
myself I was going to get out of bed at
9:00 but I hit the snooze button now it
seems trivial but in that one decision
to not keep a commitment to yourself you
wrote a little line into this the Paul
Brunson story which is actually an
instruction manual that governs your
life and this the line you wrote into
that story is I'm the type of person
that frequently isn't able to do what I
want to do right and that's an
instruction
that you then when you go to work that
when you show up when you know you think
about your big Ambitions in life it's an
instruction it's a line of code written
into who you are so I've got really
obsessed with this idea of these small
commitments and the great thing about
small things is they're easy to do and
also easy not to do but they're also
easy to do but we because they're easy
not to do and because they seem small
and trivial we tend to overlook them so
this idea that like start by keeping
these small commitments to yourself that
you make could be the the pathway to the
big results that we're seeking you know
because we look up at these these
figures on Instagram and on social media
that are like saying earlier like
running ultramarathons and they're
starting these businesses and killing
the game and we go how the [__] did they
get up there it must have been one big
decision they made it's baby steps you
know baby steps and and you said
something that I think is very important
within self-esteem and that is is that
you've exercised it there's an action
it's not just about I'm going to set my
goal as I'm going to wake up at a
certain time or I'm going to no it's
that you have you woke up at a certain
time you you you've exercised it this is
the key piece and it is it's it's it's
about all of those small steps it's
about the consistency of the small steps
and I think you you've seen this in you
must have seen this in your life is that
what that does is it builds habits that
you then build upon and then what you'll
notice is is that the the tasks become
bigger and bigger and bigger but you're
able to it because you have the
foundation of those smaller tasks I've
often wondered if there's a generation
that are kind of trapped between how
things used to be which is you know
meeting people in your village down at
church in real life and then there was
this sort of digital surge where most
people now meet online I wonder if
there's like this generation that are
trapped in between the two where they
were of a certain age where there
everyone around them was kind of meeting
um in real life they didn't manage to
meet someone then the digital age
exploded and it's literally like this
vertical line up when you look at the
graphs just suddenly everyone's meeting
online and they don't have the digital
skills they don't have the social media
they don't know how to like upload a
photo yeah but their way of dating this
IRL way of dating is now gone out of
fashion and no one's doing it yeah and
they would roughly be if I had to Hazard
a guess at their age they're
probably 35
yeah plus now 35 Plus but it's it's the
50 the 50 year olds or should I say the
45 are are getting hit and the reason
why is is exactly what you're saying but
then what's happened is so the number
one age of new daters in the world is
age 18 right we see this on the dating
apps 18 people download the dating apps
they're out on the dating scene but you
know what the number two age ranges well
I know because you said it for 55 yeah
right and why it's because of emptiness
syndrome uh you and your partner you've
had two children they go off to
University you look and you say I don't
even know you anymore I don't know you
so peace I'm gone and then you break up
and then you reenter the dating market
and you're like oh my God we we didn't
have dating apps when I was doing this
and you're completely confused as to
what to do but I'm going to tell you
something wild and that is is they end
up doing quite
well you know why because they show up
as their authentic self what we've what
we've been learning I think on social
media for so long is you know create
your
representative yeah you go to 80% maybe
even 90% of folks Instagram it's just
their representative it's it's it's not
them right and so on these dating apps
Etc it's the representative but a lot of
these people who have never used an app
before they go online they're they they
they write down the imperfect profile
they they they write they talk about
their what they're scared of what what
their fears are their vulnerabilities
they post the photos without filters
right because they don't even know how
to use a filter and you think they're
going to not do well and they end up
doing extraordinarily well because they
show up as their authentic self what the
data is showing us more than ever is
that authenticity is what wins leaning
into your quirks leaning into the things
that make you
extraordinary you know I I I I say this
all the time to to to people who I've
coached and that is is that think about
you right there have been billions of
people who have walked this planet
before you but no one ever walk this
Earth with the same experiences as you
or the same skills and guess what right
now 8 billion people in the world no one
sees the world exactly like you see it
no one has your skills no one looks
precisely like you and guess what it
gets even better because no one who will
ever live on this planet will ever look
precisely like you talk precisely like
you see the world precisely like you so
therefore guess what you are
extraordinary you are truly special you
are truly unique there's no one ever
like you so if you own that you win what
if I'm an [__] you
you well well you know what see are you
a narcissistic psychopath [__] like
you know what I mean like if you if you
if you don't like who you are you don't
want to put that out there you want to
you know filter it you know face tune it
yeah trim it cut it expand it I'm with
you I'm with you so yes many of us don't
like you know various parts of who we
are the key is to embrace the good but
going back to Carol ri's six dimensions
of psychological well-being
self-acceptance is to say you know what
these three things I do yeah [__] do
those three things but do I lay that out
no well here's what you in a dating app
no in a dating app you lay out what it
is that you desire what it is that you
are seeking but are you transparent
about those things when you're
interacting with them absolutely you're
transparent because if those [__]
traits are part of you it's going to
show up in your behavior so you alert
the person ahead of time I'm working on
these things I don't want to scare them
off no you don't but you want to be your
true self but it depends on on what kind
of trait we're talking about though so I
mean you'd have to give me example okay
I'll give you an example I um this is
I'm playing a role here okay so people
don't clip this and put it on the
internet but say that I had a toxic
trait where I get Ultra needy and I'm
like very jealous and I'm very easily
triggered by anything that makes me feel
like you're cheating on me or you're you
know I'm like insecure from like maybe
you know something that happened when I
was younger or whatever okay this is
good A lot of people have this so you'd
be very anxious the sounds very uh
typical of of of an anxious uh
attachment style so the question is is
are you working on it because if you're
if you're working on that and you
acknowledge that that's someone that
that's a great relationship to be in
because someone is proactively working
on their trauma but if you tell me this
is how I am and I'm doing nothing about
it well that's a problem I want this
relationship so I can work on it with
you no well the best time to work on
this relationship is before you're in it
goodbye that's pretty much what it is
and and but but you know what those are
the type of conversations that we should
be having how can I work on it before
the relationship so say in that case of
insecure jealous anxious type does that
mean like going to therapy and you when
you say working on it yeah okay great
question so let's first say this about
therapy I have tons of friends who are
some of the top therapists in the world
love it but when you look at the
satisfaction rate that most people
report going to therapists very low very
low if you look at the access to
therapists or top therapists very hard
to get access so most people cannot go
so I'm I'm consciously always saying
okay it's important to be able to go if
you can but most of this work you have
to do on your on your own first part is
and this is not me to be self- serving
here but I think podcasts are incredible
in creating awareness but I will say on
this particular podcast quite honestly
you've had all of the greats within this
space all of the greats from we talked
about Dr waldinger to uh Gabor mate like
you've had all of the greats who will
give you a taste of what you need to
create that awareness and then you dig
deeper you purchase the book yeah you
purchase the book and then you do the
work in the book Gabor mate all the time
he talks about you know what you you
should do let's meditate let's Journal
like he prescribes he sets it out but a
lot of us don't want to do that level of
Investigation no way we want quick easy
and now and now yeah but guess what
you're not going to get to that level of
flourishing if that's all you desire
like yeah I
mean
mediocrity is common like being mediocre
should I say is common the moment that
you can step one level above being
mediocre in society today you typically
are seen that's how low the bar is
that's the same way in relationships but
it's also the same way in the
relationship that you have with yourself
if you do any bit of work you become
exceptionally better for you for your
partner just just a little bit of work
learn to act actively listen learn to
learn to just simply
respond which is active listening versus
reacting that's a GameChanger it's the
it's this there's this idea of like
metacognition which is thinking about
your thinking and when me and my partner
have a disagreement now I it's almost
like I now have this metacognition it's
like I'm I'm watching the situation and
watching myself in the situation and it
makes such a big deal my girlfriend was
saying something to me the other day and
in my head I'm going think about how
you're listening make sure you're
listening intently make sure she feels
Hur that's what my brain is saying now
yeah that's it but before it was all
like [__] her until I need to let her
know how she's wrong yeah but see this
is the work yeah this is the work that
we were talking about that you were
doing that is work yeah but it's paying
dividend
it's like the return on investment on
learning the skills is
infinite I'm sure you take that into
your business you take that into uh
social situations active listening
stepping outside of yourself the the the
these skills change your life and to go
back to Dr waldinger's work is when
you're able to make these small
adjustments in your life you're happier
less stress you live longer you make
more money the the reward words are
infinite this older the generation that
we said we think might be trapped a
little bit in a technological transition
one of the things my friends that are
part of that generation say to me is
that there's just no people left anymore
and one of my friends has actually said
to me a few times that she needs to put
herself in a situation where she's going
to meet lots of men where there's lots
of men and she gets particularly annoyed
when her friendship group don't want to
go to the places cuz they're all paired
off okay where where they don't want
want to go to to an environment where
there's lots of men does it matter you
talk about this in chapter 4 the
importance of the sex ratio yes yeah
does it matter so sex ratio is huge the
best example of sex ratio is look at
what's happening in the Farmland so
country areas of
China where you had the basically the
one child policy where you see a heavy
number of men so the sex ratio is the
number of uh women to men
right and so you look at the number of
men there's many more men than there are
women in in in China especially in the
farm area of China so what what does
that mean what that means is that women
now have more negotiation power with the
men if you go back 40 years you'd have
to be buried off by 18 17 16 in some of
those areas you would have no say as to
who you could now I literally just read
an article where you have 30 plusy old
women going into those areas saying we
can choose whoever we want out here you
know we can do whatever we want you have
more negotiation power but that also
impacts the relationships that then do
form for example look at most University
campuses that now have majority women at
the University campuses what's happening
in terms of sex at the
campuses off the charts why because you
have a small pool of men who say you
know what we now have negotiation power
there there there's few of us there's
all these women out here and and and
what's what's happening is the women are
looking at the small pool of men and
saying okay we only have access to these
guys the guys know okay we have access
to all of these women so therefore we're
going to act a fool you know and what
ends up happening is you end you end up
seeing how
relationships change the formation
changes based on sex ratio so looking at
at some of these macroeconomics you can
see how it does impact how a
relationship is formed and then what
happens in the
relationship there there's some
environments that are and there's some
professions that are typically dominated
by one gender typically for whatever
reason in the book you talk about like
engineering degree courses yes so if I
was a woman and I would say I was just
you know I was 20 years old and I was
desperate to find a man going into a
engineering degree course
would put leverage on my side yes it's
just something to think about you know
people choosing jobs and environments to
work in if they are really trying to
expose themselves to a gender balance
that's in their favor we're talking
about heterosexual heterosexual couples
here then that is something to consider
it it is but even that point is
controversial right because that point
that you just mentioned which I endorse
by the way then I'll cut it
out it's all controversial no but but
the reason why I say that points
controversial but I love it is because
what you're saying is you're saying hey
young lady you're going off you're
thinking about your career also start
thinking about your long-term partner at
the same time I I feel as if a large
narrative that's placed on us in Western
Society is knock out the education and
the career get all of that taken care of
then once you have all of that wrapped
up nicely now you could focus on these
other things things in life I have sat
at the deathbed of two people in my life
I will never forget these moments ever
what they did is they both said the same
things these were you know two different
people different times they both died
within 24 hours of me seeing them they
said this thing life it goes by fast
goes by fast the second thing is they
begin recounting the the intimate
relationships that they had
with all of their with with their loved
ones you know they're they're they're
recollecting this now there's other
things that they'll talk about certain
regrets wanting to be happier wanting to
have done certain things but ultimately
it's about I remember the good times
with the people I love the most so
what's interesting to me about that is
there's no talk about their career
there's no talk about what they
accomplished professionally
there's no talk about what they learned
in school so does that then mean that
the most important facets of our life
are the relationships that we form I
would say yes and then if that's the
case why don't we focus on those things
earlier let's focus on that that's the
reason why I love that statement because
yes you know I my my sons are 10 and 13
already I'm like look let's talk about
your partners let's talk about how
you're going to go about doing this
because ultimately that will be the most
important decision that you make in life
so let's talk about kids and dating then
we talked about Boomers a little bit
there's this word in your book
pronounced
hyper gamy yeah hypergamy that's exactly
what I said H hypergamy
hypergamy seeking partners of higher
Social Status is notable in online
dating what is what is hyper game me
yeah yeah yeah and and with I want to
talk about genz because you said a
statement at the start of this
conversation about them being the most
successful in marriages and your
forecasting yes yes okay so all right
hypergamy is a topic that gets a lot of
push back but it is what it is we
can't we we cannot um disagree with all
of the data and what the and what that
suggests is essentially someone who is
Seeking a partner of equal or greater
resources men and women well it's it's
it's it's it's always categorized as
heterosexual women okay seeking a
heterosexual man of equal or greater
resources and the data that typically
people point to is when they look at um
degrees college degrees and they look at
women in in in online dating so they say
okay let's look at um women in online
dating across different dating apps and
we'll look at all of those with a
college degree who is it that they
typically swipe right on or who is it
that they typically select and on
average it's men who have at least a
college degree or greater master's
degree right and the
whole push back that I think ends up
happening is you see people say well
there it is right there these women are
all opportunists that's what they're
looking for they're looking for just
opportunity and I say hold on for a
second do you realize first that for
hundreds of thousands of years this was
the structure this was the only
structure you needed we've talked about
it you must have chosen if you're a
woman you must have chosen a partner
that had equal or greater resources if
you wanted to
survive to next week so why is it still
here or next year well you know why
because the patriarchy has not been
destroyed it it is it is not been
destabilized it's because modern
relationships these relationships around
self-expression just started
1960 I mean I I think it's it is
fascinating to think that women just
began to have choice and remember we're
talking about these weird Western IND
educated industrialized right Rich
democratic nations have just begun to
have a bit of choice you you know what I
mean a bit of choice just now so
therefore we're living in a day and age
where you you can't you you can't argue
against this you know you you when I say
you can't argue against it is is you
have to understand why that is but the
reason why I say I believe that gen Z
will have the strongest marriages is I
also think they'll have the fewest
marriages of any
generation
marriage is without question on the
decline
without question you can't argue cannot
argue it's on the decline but what we're
going to see is we're going to see a
small percentage of people who decide to
join in Union in what we're today
calling marriage and they will have
exceptionally strong marriages because
they'll have consciously chosen to go
into this Union they'll have the tools
and they'll help each other to you know
to to self-evolve so unless kids
they'll have less kids yeah are you
concerned about that the sort of decline
of people having kids I'm I'm quite
aware of of of some of this data right
and this replacement rate this rate of
us not having enough children to meet
the replacement rate which I think on
average is typically like 2.1 right so
you think that in the United States or
in the UK in Japan where I know this is
this is hitting heavy uh really all
throughout most of the world but I want
to get to where it's not happening but
through most of the world what you have
is you have people not having enough
children to meet the replacement rate
what's the replacement rate so that is
the number of new births that need to
happen in order to replace the Aging
dying population ah okay so typically
it's it's like it's 2.1 right uh but
we're not couples are getting together
they're having 1.8 you know or one or
one or whatever it may be now what that
means is it means precisely what you
said and that is is that we will have an
older population and as a result of
having an older population we won't be
able to do all the things that we need
for that older population think about
the tax base who's going to support the
older population in terms of monetary
resources physically who's going to be
in the nursing homes to support an older
population who's going to be at home or
who and so the
underpopulation is I believe it is a
real issue however it gets very
political and the reason why I think it
gets political and I've seen uh have you
heard of uh Neo natalism no in natalism
no was that uh so it is when you begin
to look at
underpopulation based on nationality or
ethnicity
and when you begin to look deeper you
say hold on for a second the world is
beginning to slowly become
underpopulated but if you look at
Nigeria yeah it's going off it's going
off I have no Nigerian friend that
doesn't have like eight 10 brothers and
sisters you know and like to this day
and if you look at it's not just Nigeria
like you look at West Africa you look at
different pockets of mostly what's
considered to be black populations Brown
populations you see that the
population is growing you know when I um
David McQueen did an exhibit here in
London that blew me away was it was at
the tape Gallery it was called the year3
he took photos of every year three class
in London and he puts hundreds and
hundreds of photos up in the tape
gallery and you walk in right and at
that time my son was year three so I
walk in and you look at this thing and
you say oh my gosh this is what London
is going to look like in the
future and you know what it is it's
mostly black mostly Muslim and I think
that what you're seeing in the natalism
Neo natalism movement is you're seeing a
lot of people who are scared by that and
they say to themselves okay what we need
to do is we need to figure out how we
can produce more offspring of a
particular ethnicity or of a particular
nationality you've begun to see
presidential candidates in the United
States talk about this uh it is I think
an
extremely
dangerous category and area to to to to
to to to uh to to or or or an idea it's
a dangerous idea to to to put forth
forward in the future it's going to be
one of the top issues that that we're
debating because if you play that
forward not long you wouldn't have to
play it forward very long to realize
that there's certain races that will be
that will once the majority that would
then become a minority race oh yeah in
the UK it's already been predicted that
by I think it's roughly 2050 that you're
going to have roughly half or greater
than half of the population in the UK be
black or brown I'm not talking about
uh London I'm not talking about England
I'm talking about in the UK that to me
is absolutely it's mind-blowing it's
mind-blowing to think about that and
when some people think about that
they're excited by by by by that future
they're saying okay this is wonderful
but there are other people who hear that
and they become very scared and that
fear I think is facilitating a lot of
these more extreme ideas that are very
very
dangerous isn't this cool every single
conversation I have here on the DI of
CEO at the very end of it you'll know I
asked the guest to leave a question in
the Diary of a CEO and what we've done
is we've turned every single question
written in the Diary of a CEO into these
conversation cards that you can play at
home so you've got every guest we've
ever had their question and on the back
of it if you scan that QR code you get
to watch the person who answered that
question we're finally revealing all of
the questions and the people that
answered the question the brand new
version 2 updated conversation cards are
out right now at the conversation
cards.com as you'll know if you've
listened to this podcast before I'm an
investor in a company called hu I'm on
their board and they sponsor this
podcast Daily Greens which is this
powder I have in front of me for those
of you that can see that gives you some
incredible health benefits your energy
your concentration your immunity is now
available in the UK for the 91 vitamins
and minerals you get from it the
adaptogens the daily green probiotics
that are within this blend and for the
last year or so all of you on this
podcast that have dm'd me about this
product have asked when it will be
coming to the UK it's now here if you're
someone that wants to get more greens
into your diet then I highly recommend
giving it a go not only is it good for
you but it tastes good win-win the
product was so popular in the US that it
sold out over and over again and I think
that's what's going to happen here in
the UK so get your hands on it now just
give it a try take a picture tag me DM
me let me know what you think of it and
because I think it's going to become one
of your staple products if you're
someone that's looking for a greens
product in your life then I really
believe that this will probably become
your staple as it has become mine before
we get into this some of these key
questions which are really things we
talked about earlier but like what
should I be looking for an a partner and
what should I not be looking for an a
partner I wanted to quickly go over this
thing called attachment Theory because
in our last conversation it's one of the
most replayed moments from our previous
conversation just to summarize
attachment Theory because I think this
is quite key to talk about what we what
we're going to talk about next what are
the four categories of attachments in
adults yeah all right so uh Mary
answorth is really the person that led
us to attachment Theory she worked with
John Balby but Mary answorth really
American Canadian psychologist and let's
just talk about the the test that she
gave because I think it adds uh context
so so she essentially would take a a
child and a caregiver and she would take
this child she did did this in Baltimore
of all places she would take this child
in in a primary caregiver and would walk
into a room with the child and the
caregiver or she would allow the child
and the caregiver to walk into a room
and the caregiver would leave and then
momentarily come back now if the child
saw the caregiver leave there would be
distress oh my gosh I can't believe this
maybe there's some crying maybe there
there's some yelling then when the
caregiver comes back if the child
immediately soothed okay my caregiver is
back I'm okay that was considered to be
secure secure attachment now if the
caregiver left and came back and the
child was distressed when the caregiver
left came back and still a little
distressed but okay but I'm not sure you
going to leave again don't leave please
right the back and forth that was
considered anxious anxious attachment
then the third because at that time
there was three primary the third was
the caregiver would come back and the
child would say whatever you know that
was avoidant so these were the three
fundamental uh attachment
Styles and what her work then LED is to
other researchers Sue Johnson Etc to
then apply that to how we show up as
adults and Dr LaVine in his book
attached then starts to write about
attachment but I want to say say
something very important that I've not
heard I've actually not heard anyone
talk about with attachment and that is
is that we have to understand that
attachment is phenomenal in
understanding how we show up as adults
and how we relate but we have to
understand this is a very Western
concept and the reason why I say that is
because there's been some small tests
done in Uganda some small tests done in
Japan around attachment and do you know
what happen
when the caregiver in
Japan left the the child and comes back
that the child would freak out would be
under complete distress that the
caregiver left and when the child came
when the caregiver came back the child
would continue to be under duress and
stress but that was considered a secure
attachment so you think what hold on for
a second that same child that that would
have been anxious in the US but but
that's secure in Japan why is that well
the reason why is because when you
investigate how the child was reared you
realize that in certain areas of the
world mostly collectivist or Eastern
societies that child the that uh
caregiver typically the mother would
never leave the child so therefore a
secure attachment was always or the
child recognize the the caregiver as
always being there always being there
and so that's the reason why the child
felt so much distress when the even when
the when the when the caregiver came
back but the reason why I say this is
because I think what ends up happening
with attachment style and I've I I've
seen this in
different different concepts that get
introduced which are very important but
what we see is we always see it through
this Western lens yeah we have to
realize we're living in a global world
right where many of us have lineage or
parents who are from different parts of
the world and so therefore we have to
respect all parts and therefore um it
it's just it's it's just important to
know that attachment style or you're
talking about love language or whatever
it may be these are good
Concepts but we have to understand that
these are
not globally applicable
mhm they're very narrow um in that
regard and you know we for some reason
we're all drawn to these when we can
just when there's just three and we just
pick the one we are and then it gives us
all the answers that's makes life much
easier than the complexity of the truth
yes so let's let's not burst the
illusion
Paul we like
L but it's I think yeah I I relate most
to this idea of being the anxious
preoccupied one who probably wouldn't
care when they came back in the room
sorry no I got that wrong yeah you're
avoidant yes I'm avoidant yes yeah yeah
and but but you know what interest okay
you know what um well since we're on
attachment style I've got to go here is
there's some phenomenal research that's
been done around attachment style and
sex right you ready for this cut the
cameras a second cut the cameras are
they off they're off okay okay go ahead
yeah this this this is some phenomenal
research that that that that blows my
mind so um these researchers looked at
the number of
orgasms that people have based on their
attachment style and the type of sexual
interaction it is so a one night stand
you could probably guess this a one
night stand or um uh a one night or
let's say a one night stand or casual
sex if you are secure
or you were anxious you despise that the
the data showed that the percentage of
people who had orgasms in one night
stands or casual sex was substantially
low if they were uh if they were secure
or anxious but if they were
avoidant off the charts why is because
the avoidance were like oh man I don't
like I don't want the the the emotional
connection to it right and I and I think
it's just important to see okay well
attachment Styles it does play into how
we interact and why but when you
understand who you are you could begin
to to shift those
patterns I'm sure a lot of people can
relate in various ways so you're saying
that you're much less likely to have an
orgasm on a one night stand if you are a
needy or a secure because you just won't
it won't be connecting with you you
won't be as able to be psychologically
safe in that context absolutely just as
an
avoidant has less number of orgasms in a
Friends with Benefits
scenario why because you have to give up
some emotional intimacy as an avoidant
in a friends with benefit situation
right and whereas secure would have a
slightly higher than they would with
with a one night stand so all of this is
really about all of this at the end of
the day it's about really knowing who
you are and why you are knowing
attachment style knowing about your
traumas in life knowing about your
triggers knowing about how you
communicate when you know all of these
things you become a master of your
environment Marcus Garvey from Jamaica
right would always say become the the
person who becomes a master of self
becomes a master of their environment it
always begins with self I've got to dig
deeper on this point of sex because it
made me ask the question that does that
suggest avoidance in the bedroom will
like a different type of sex to a
anxious like an avoidant might prefer a
sex that is a little bit
less intimate right if you know what I
mean so uh I'm going to be assuming here
yeah but I think this is a topic I I
need to study now I'm going to do I
think I'm do research study on this
seriously is I'm willing to bet that an
avoidant definitely has different sexual
boundaries and different sexual
interests than secure or anxious because
ultimately what what what is driving the
avoidant is saying I don't want the
emotional intimacy that comes with this
event so anything that's driving the
emotional intimacy I prefer not to have
it right so I would I would willing to
bet a voice like let's not really talk
we don't need to talk is it do we need
to talk no we don't need to talk about
no that's kissing no that's n let's not
kiss whereas I I I would willing to bet
a
secure wants and needs
that it's a good study and an anxious oh
oh I mean even more so an anxious
probably needs two days of foreplay you
know before and avoiding just want a
transaction just wants a transaction
right let's make it efficient maybe
that's part of the reason you know last
time we spoke I was speaking about
different sex languages the the way I
described it was figuring out that my
girlfriend was speaking Spanish and I
was speaking like French in the bedroom
and we just needed to find a mutual
language or I speak a little bit of
French he speaks a little bit of Spanish
whatever this is a metaphor for
different types of sort of sexual
preference or fantasy or things that
turn you on but maybe that goes to
explain why so many couples are
struggling in the bedroom because one of
them wants a certain type of Sex and the
other wants much more emotional sex yes
this is such an important
topic because I think when you can see
your partner through that lens it's no
longer oh my God can you believe it he
didn't even want to kiss me like he's a
he you know he's he's he's this he's
he's an [__] but what it could be is
that he is severely avoidant this is
what he learned from his parents and
these are behaviors that can change so
let's work on the behaviors like I I I
rarely do we have bad people rarely yes
we there's a whole cohort of of of the
dark tetrad there there are bad people
but most people are good but simply have
bad behaviors we can work on the
behaviors or just different behaviors
right different Behavior that's true
that's true that's true different
behaviors I'm really just pondering this
idea of these
avoidance cuz I'm an avoidant and none
of my fantasies none of the things that
really turn me on involve like talking
and and like you know that like the the
things that you think of which is all
about like emotional connection and all
that stuff those aren't the things that
I I hold as like fantasies right those
aren't the things and I was thinking
about how our fantasies are derived from
our much of our like trauma and our our
our upbringing and our disconnection and
our you know if you were if you were
bullied in school I I see this a lot
actually I remember it just took flat my
head flashbacks when I was 18 and I met
a guy and one of his fantasies that he
was very vocal about was because he he
was powerless when he was younger he was
powerless in school and so he liked
using terminology in the bedroom I
remember him saying this to me that made
him feel empowered and I remember
thinking what a [__] weirdo like at
the time yeah because it seemed a little
bit sadistic what he was saying but to
think that something that happens on the
playground can translate right to the
bedroom when you're 35 years old and the
thing that gives you an erection is
pretty pretty interesting it's worth
some further inspection it is I mean how
we our
experiences at home as we grew up are
experiences on the playground our
experiences with our first lovers but
even beyond that the experiences that
our great grandparents
had the wars that they were in the
Holocaust that they were in the
transatlantic slave trade that they were
a part of all of these
intergenerational bits of trauma right
all of these things shape how we show up
it shapes who you are today it shapes
who who I am today and that's why we
have to go back and understand this and
when you can understand that you can
more fully appreciate your partner you
know just like you're saying with your
friend I I think it it's it's it's so
great because you're saying okay when I
heard this that was it sound a crazy
talk but now I understand so we could
begin to dialogue about this you know
and it's and it's an interesting
question whether his fetish is wrong and
it's needs fixing and it's like yuck or
if it's just different mhm and I guess
that comes down to whether it hurts
anybody yeah I guess that's the key
exactly filter exactly if if if it hurts
it's he he's he's in the sadist category
uh and and that's something that should
be
addressed chapter seven of your book is
what to look for in a relationship yes
now I think this is a really really
important subject
because this is often where many people
go wrong and I went many I went wrong
for many many years by having this kind
of list of superficial things
we talked earlier about how women are
typically on average looking for someone
that has the same sort of academic level
of qualification as them in various
studies and there's multiple websites
now where you can go on and input what
you're looking for and these websites
tell you what chance you have of finding
that and I think much of the purpose of
these websites is just to illuminate the
fact that like it doesn't exist upstairs
before I came downstairs the reason I
was a couple of minutes late is I was
sat upstairs with my friend who's
upstairs watching now big fan of yours
and I asked them the questions I said
can you just tell me what you're looking
for in a man okay and there's only five
questions that one of these websites
asks it says these are the five
questions do you want someone is married
or not married person upstairs said not
married okay okay good check check what
race do you want them to be ideally and
I told them to be honest with me they
said why I said okay I said get out
you my friend how dare you um so they
said not married in white and I said how
high and she muled and she molded and
she she was like that and then she said
ideally I mean 6'2 or 63 but you know I
guess I should say and then she said 6
foot so I put in 62 okay and then I said
and then the fourth question is obese or
not obese she said not obese and I said
what amount of money do you want them to
earn she came out with 150k yeah right
sounds about right pounds in pounds so I
converted that to dollars for this
website the last question that I asked
was about the age range oh man right so
what age range do you want the person to
be and I believe she said yeah she said
31 to 45 wow okay okay so that narrows
it down further and then using data from
the 2020 annual social and economic
supplement the E the
ASC of the current population survey in
the united in the United States done by
the Census Bureau of the United States
this gives her a
0.046% chance of finding the person
there you go how' she how'd she
respond it was like that same sound
of [__] yeah but I but I think that's
important because it go it leads into
what we're about to talk about which
is what should we be caring about what
should we be looking for because listen
if we're looking for someone that's You
Know Rich tall a certain race
certain certain
am and is not married when we thinking
about we're really setting ourselves up
for failure in many respects it's really
limiting us to a very small pool of
individuals we we we are so what is it
that you need from all of my research it
has come down 10 years of research on
this is I think there's five key
characteristics that we need one is you
need a partner who's emotionally fit
that's nowh on those questions question
I guarantee you she's right now saying
yes Paul I need emotionally fit I think
she's going I need a
$250,000 no no I'm going to convince her
on this emotional Fitness is far greater
than any amount of money and here's the
reason why emotional fit means that you
are emotionally stable you are
emotionally intelligent but but let me
talk about emotional stability this is
this is so important is that
in relationships what I often hear
people not mention at all is something
called Low
neuroticism that's being emotionally
stable now what is that that means that
when your partner goes through a high or
a low or you go through a high or a low
you still show up as the same person now
why is this important because life is
filled with ups and downs constantly I
would say that the moment I knew my wife
wife was the one that I wanted to marry
her was when my grandfather passed away
it was a crushing blow I loved him
dearly he passes away she dropped
everything to drive me eight hours she
went she she she did she went over and
Beyond to support me and she never
changed her behaviors never changed she
was always the same loving person when
she lost her job she lost her job when
we were dating never changed it was it
was demoralizing but she was still kind
to me right and and and and so to have
someone who's emotionally stable who can
go through the lows still remain
themselves is incredibly important so
you need someone who's emotionally fit
that's one second is you need someone
who has courageous Vision right and and
this speaks to Carol rift's six
dimensions of psychological well-being
you want someone who feels like they're
on the path to something because if you
don't feel like you're on the path to
something you are stuck in mediocrity
you are you you you don't have any drive
to get up in the morning right or you
you you you there's no assertiveness to
to to to how you show up in life so you
need someone that has a vision for
themselves in in life so so that's very
important you know next you need someone
who is I call it resiliently resourceful
very important when times are hard
someone who's res briliantly resourceful
they could bounce back like yeah I'm
going to be knocked down cuz you will be
knocked down see you must have been
knocked down all the time countless
right but what do you do you get back up
and you figure out a way how do I take
all of these pieces that have been
cracked and how do I create a beautiful
Mosaic out of those pieces that's
resilient resourcefulness incredibly
important then you need someone who's
open-minded right open-minded
understanding ultimately what does that
mean that means curiosity
and I say this curiosity is one of the
sexiest traits in the world curiosity
because if you have a partner who's
curious what will they do they want to
know everything about you they listen
they listen to you and they care about
what they're hearing and that allows you
to have strong emotional intimacy so
that's very important and then last is
you need someone who's going to give you
compassionate support someone who's
going to be there for you you know when
you get knocked down I'm right here for
you if you have these traits you have
the makings of the strongest partner for
you and that person doesn't have to test
highly in all those categories they just
simply need to be on the pathway to
realizing those because if you have
someone who embodies those
characteristics you have someone who
could resolve conflict with you but then
what does they say about online data and
dating apps because there's no dating
app that helps to illuminate emotional
Fitness the courageous Vision the
resilient resourcefulness the
open-mindedness The Compassion
compassionate supportive focus and
kindness and empathy that you talk about
there's no dating apps that put that
front and center I have to make a
decision on these dating apps within 0.1
seconds just based on you know does
their face look like Paul brunson's yeah
do they have shoulders like yeah but I
mean so it feels like every time I come
now I'm pitching you a dating app we
should we should
do no one would download this dating app
though that's the truth yeah see this is
why I've written this book right what
what I'm saying here is that is
attraction important yeah it's still
important I I I say that there's five
fundamentals but then there's also some
Dynamics we need we need to make sure
that we're physically attracted to the
person we need to have the same
relationship goals that's important we
need to make sure that U you know we can
resolve conflict together all all of
these pieces are important but what I'm
telling you is without question these
five fundamentals are the most important
now I believe that as our needs change
the technology will adapt to how our
needs change think about gen Z for
example gen Z is saying physical
attraction is important but my
willingness and desire to be authentic
is even more important so already we're
changing even on Tinder we're changing
we're allowing more options for people
to disclose more and more about
themselves so I think that the
technology will change as we depict our
needs to change as our needs change in
your book chapter 8 you talk about this
and you said the word earlier the dark
tetrad yes dark
tetrad
narcissists they exhibit attractive
qualities at the beginning of a
relationship right because that's
characterized by being sort of self
assured like on the surface it seems
like confidence yes you know yes there's
some great research around speed dating
and it looked at who are the most
successful when it comes to speed dating
and you know who the most successful are
two types of people narcissists and
Psychopaths they're the most successful
at speed dating now why is it the truth
what you were just saying they show up
as self assured as confident but you
know what else they do they're willing
to lie they're willing to tell you
anything you want to hear to get what
they want because that's their objective
their objective is to use you like this
cup of of of water right here when I'm
done drinking this water the cup is gone
I don't need it anymore that's how a
narcissist or a psychopath shows up and
so that's the reason why they're they're
they're Ultra successful is there a
certain type of person that's more PR to
be attracted to narcissists yes I mean
Psychopaths yeah they're definitely
there there's there's there's different
personality types that enable themselves
to a to anyone in the dark tetrad but in
essence what it is is in essence it's
going to be someone who is not secure
and it's going to be someone who has low
self-esteem because when you have low
self-esteem you're seeking that
validation you're seeking their
confirmation their affirmation of you
and the more that they distance
themselves they distance themselves from
you the more you want their affirmation
they probably see you as an easy target
as well they beam right into you and
they destroy your life they destroy your
life I I I think that the term
narcissism or narcissist is one of the
most overused words probably like in
modern-day dating everyone is a
narcissist but but everyone is not a
narcissist they're just a bit selfish
yep just a bit selfish just a bit of an
[__] AR yeah just a little arrogant
people have narcissistic traits but when
you're talking about a clinically
diagnosed narcissist that is an
extremely dangerous person how many
people are within this dark tetrad that
you talk about and the dark tetrad is
narcissism psychopathy machism and
sadism right and sadism absolutely so
those those four make up the dark tetrad
and on average the estimate is less than
15 15% so less than 15% of the
population fall within one of those
categories now it's important to say
that that category extremely dangerous
to the point where a narcissist once a
narcissist always a
narcissist and so the question always to
me is well Paul I found out that my my
partner is is a
narcissist what do I do well I say
if you want to remain in a relationship
with someone that is going to
continually use you and may learn to
manage their behavior but will always
see you as an object to
use than stay in the relationship but
otherwise you have to leave what one of
my friends is one of the top experts on
narcissism in the world and when I sit
down I always say are you sure you can't
change if you're a narcissist like I
just met that he's a great guy like she
she she she without question you cannot
and she works with with with with
narcissists and tells me how she's able
to teach them how to just manage what it
is that they do but if you are someone
and and and your partner is and I'm not
talking about they have narcissistic
traits you know arrogant Etc I'm talking
about they are they've been clinically
diagnosed as a narcissist you are in for
an extremely extremely hard life with
them how' you spot a narcissist oh my
God I me you know so people talk about
love bombing all the time but but but
ultimately a narcissist's objective is
to use you for whatever it is like to
use you use you use you for for their
pleasure they could have some
machiavellianism mixed in because a lot
of the dark tetrad the characteristics
overlap where Mackie evanism is about
strategy specifically for their pleasure
so the key is to look at their
behavior and to look at their behavior
over a long period of time and this is
where it gets fatiguing but important so
the studies show that when you are in a
committed
relationship committed for two years on
average and then you get married the
divorce rate is substantially lower
right we found that the the divorce rate
is 20 22% now why is that it's because
you've had the opportunity to see your
partner in the ups and downs in the
highs and lows right to see if they have
low neuroticism can they bounce back to
see are they using you for whatever
their purposes are the challenge is a
lot of us see the
behavior and decide to stay you know why
we decide to stay because that list that
you he makes over 100,000 he's over six
feet he's this he's that he checks these
boxes that mean nothing to my happiness
truly means nothing to your happiness it
means something to the validation that
you're getting from the public but to
your actual well-being it's
insignificant it's
nothing but they check those boxes so
therefore I'm going to stay and you're
going to stay and this is what you're
going to get when you stay you're going
to live under duress you're going to
feel lonely you're going to feel
isolated your cortisol levels are going
to go up you're going to get
inflammation you're more susceptible to
disease you're going to die early you
are going to be miserable
why it's interesting when you're talking
about understanding their relationship
history because a narcissist wouldn't
tell you but then it got me thinking
about this idea of like cheating and
infidelity and betrayal in previous
relationships and I wanted to ask you
this random question which is if you
find out your partner has previously
cheated in other relationships is that a
red flag I mean I don't necessarily
necessarily uh ascribe to Red hard fast
like because I believe that behavior can
be can can can can can change so is
anything a red flag other than this dark
tetrad no nothing's a red flag there's
no such thing I think the dark tetrad is
is the red flag and no effort is the red
flag if criminal history at all I I you
know this is this is interesting I have
plenty of family members who have been
incarcerated and who are some of the
best people in the world I've met a lot
of them actually met a lot of
incarcerated people that are morally
better more sound than anybody I know
than anybody I know I would trust them
with my to to to with my child you know
um I think no effort is a red flag when
you have a partner who says n that
therap I'm not going to do that
what watch a a video on active listening
I'm not going to do that uh what you're
talking about we need to do a trust
exercise no no I'm I'm not that is a red
flag the dark tetrad those are red flags
I can't think of any others I had a
really random question I wanted to ask
you as well which is um if you don't
want to do something in a relationship
it kind of leads to what you were just
saying there if you don't want to do
something should did you tell your
partner so your wife goes to you Paul
hey Paul I want to go watch this ballet
thing um do you want to
come in that moment you have no desire
to go and watch the ballet yes right how
how does one respond are you asking for
for a friend for a friend yeah for a
friend oh my God all right no cuz like
something I've been thinking about a lot
lately which is like me and my partner
have talked about it a lot which is if I
ask her if she wants to do something yes
should
she tell me the truth and go no I don't
want to go watch Manchester United play
or should she should just come along and
do it because she should be helping me
meet my needs yeah all right to answer
that question it's really about your
history in resolving conflict and have
you been able to resolve conflict as a
partnership in a healthy way because
what we what ends up happening in
relationships is let's say before she
asked you about Manchester United right
you've had a disagreement but the
disagreement was not resolved and
there's pain on her side pain on your
side well she's going to learn and it
will be reinforced to not be truthful
with you because she knows that you as a
couple have an inability to resolve
conflict and therefore she wants to
protect herself and often times what
ends up happening in relationships is
that
patterns toxic behaviors patterns are
reinforced time and time and time again
so you get to a point where of course
you can't tell each other the truth cuz
the moment that you do it's it's a it's
a it's there's an explosion that's why
it's important you have to build a great
relationship is just like you're just
adding a layer on top of a layer on top
of a layer on top of a layer very thin a
piece of paper and every time that
you're able to do something good as a
partnership every time you affirm your
partner she affirms you you resolve
conflict whatever it may be it's another
layer that's added to to to that
partnership and as you're growing and
you're growing it affords you the
opportunity to be more bluntly
transparent to the point where I walk
out my wife's like why you have those
leather trousers on like those are
ridiculous like we're at the point where
we can in a most blunt way you know be
ridiculously authentic with each other
and it's because we have Stacks and
stacks and Stacks and stacks of previous
Foundation of History
so I can't immediately say walk out and
be ultra transparent because I don't
know what the history is but if you have
a strong history and you're able to
resolve conflict in a healthy way then
you are able to be even more transparent
it's you know relationships are this
constant balance of checking in
understanding your partner's feelings
affirming what those feelings are
understanding your desires what your
feelings are ensuring that they're
affirmed it's constant it's constantly
moving which is why I always say it's
like the the the marriage there's never
stagnation in a or in a partnership
you're never just this you're either
growing or the relationship is dying
like there there's no in between [__]
there's no in between but it sounds like
it's growing sounds like yours you know
is growing it is growing because do you
know why it's growing because of the
thing you said earlier which is because
of effort and because both parties care
to put in the effort and so there must
be so many people I would Hazard a guess
that the majority of people are the 80%
that you described earlier you said
there's 20% that are happier than ever
and 80% that are less satisfied than
ever I would has to Guess that there's
an 80% of listeners out there now that
are in a relationship where they realize
that the effort is gone and it went they
don't know when it went maybe it was
when they had kids and work be became
really really busy but at some point
along the way way effort became
deprioritized yeah and there was a
belief
that things would stay the same even
without nutrients and water and sunlight
yes you know what I mean but there's no
nothing in nature can grow without
continual nourishment of some form so
chapter nine my last question
okay in chapter nine of your book you
talk about John godman's Four Horsemen
yes what are the four horsemen okay so
John gotman phenomenal I'd say one of
the top researchers on what it takes for
a marriage to sustain itself and he
analyzed hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of of of couples and he
actually would break them down into six
second increments because he would he
would he would videotape them and he
would look at how they interact with
with each other and he determined that
based on how how they interact with each
other is indicative of if they will stay
together in a relationship and he
identified these
four uh attributes if you will these
four types of interaction that suggest
you know what things are a little shaky
and one of the four he if he sees with
99% accuracy he believes they will break
up so what are they one is
criticism one is
defensiveness a third is Stone Walling
but here's the biggest and I see this a
lot
contempt if you have a partner who shows
you contempt as Dr gotman would say
there's a 99% likelihood you you'll
break up as a couple now why is that the
reason why is because real contempt
suggests that you are on a whole another
level than your partner it's a level of
disrespect you're saying to your partner
you're no long longer on my level and
you can see contempt show up in these
small 6-second increments you you're
watching a couple you know I see it all
the time I see couples um arguing and
you see the eye roll the Look Away the
look back in just those moments One
partner is saying you're not even on my
level like you shouldn't even be my
presence right when you see that level
of disrespect coming from your partner
you know they don't they don't respect
you
they don't value you and so the the the
Four Horsemen of of the Apocalypse is is
is real and it's something that we need
to be aware of because when we're aware
of these things we we we can witness are
they showing up with our partner or are
they showing up with us where does that
contempt start what is the seed that
grows into contempt it it it could it
could start from a myriad of places you
know I fundamentally believe it begins
with us selecting bad Partners you know
it begins with us choosing a partner
that we have very little hope of
completing the Finish Line with you know
what I mean and so we are not on the
same page in terms of our relationship
goals maybe we don't share the same
values um you know our partner is not
kind to us we can't resolve conflict and
then every small
interaction there's another hairline
fracture another hairline fracture
another hairline fracture and it grows
most relationships don't break up
because of one incident they break up
because of hundreds of small little
incidents that happen over the course of
time and you get to a point where you
cannot take it anymore that's how most
relationships break up so how do we stop
those small incidents then compounding
into a divorce is it is it about
conflict resolution oh yeah the the top
reason why most researchers will say
that we break up or we divorce is
they'll point to finance or they'll say
infidelity or they but really what it is
to me what I believe it is is it's our
inability to resolve the conflict about
those topics so so so conflict
resolution becomes one of the
key drivers towards a highly satisfied
relationship but it begins before that
it begins with us reflecting on us doing
the woo work and saying am I happy like
when I wake up do I wake up with a smile
on my face when I go to sleep like am I
content am I happy with where I am at
life do I do I feel like you know I'm
not where I want to be but but do I feel
like I'm on the pathway if you're
answering yes to those things you are in
a place of satisfaction which means that
your light is on which means that I
guarantee you the people in your life
their light is on you're meeting more
people you're interacting with greater
people you have a greater ability to
meet new people meet people share those
same desires and their light is on as
well if your light is not on and you're
checking boxes then you're most likely
going to meet someone and their light
won't be on but they're checking boxes
so you're already starting in a place
where your relationship is doomed to
fail Cheryl Samberg 2014 her book uh
leanin when she wrote that book it blew
me away because she she said who you
choose as a partner
is the most important career decision
you could make then a couple years later
Warren Buffett comes out in his uh
documentary and he says who you choose
as a partner is the most important
decision you could make and when I heard
that I thought to myself W this this is
interesting because I was seated in
finance and I thought it was about my
network and education and who you know
but really as I began to look at the
people who were the most satisfied in my
life it was always the people who had
the strongest Intimate
Relationships Paul we have a closing
tradition on this podcast where the last
guest leaves a question for the next
guest the question left for you
is what things are you doing that are
contributing to keeping you stuck or
stopping you from progressing wow in the
way that you would like oh
wow I still fight with
feeling that I I feel like I'm the
underdog all the
time and I think there's so many things
that I
overanalyze that I shouldn't be but I
I'll I'll give you an example and this
is this is a this is real and and I know
people can empathize with this is you
know sometimes I'll I'll talk to someone
and I'll say you know are are you
responding to me that way because I'm a
black man is that why are you responding
to me that way because I'm American are
you responding to me that way because
I'm whatever you see me on tele like I'm
always second guessing what I'm hearing
and I think it's because I view myself
as this Underdog maybe not worthy not
enough that I am
overanalyzing the positive is that it
gives me extra drive an extra assert an
extra I'm goingon to go kill it because
because of that but the downside is that
I think I'm creating
barriers and
roadblocks and maybe they're just asking
me the question because they're curious
you know maybe they're genuinely
interested and that's the reason why the
question is being asked like maybe I am
I'm I'm it's it's I'm I'm adding too
much to to what it is I'm I'm I'm
overthinking it but I think all of this
is holding me back I would like to be
able to just more so free flow with life
and not think of it as chess I think of
it as chess you know and I want to think
of it less as chess chess is is uh is is
exhausting exhausting yeah Checkers is
so much
easier Paul thank thank you you've um
you've written a unbelievably great book
and the accessibility of this book The
timeliness of this book and the um the
wisdom that is poured into all of these
Pages both qualitative and quantitative
research over you know the the amount of
incredible people that I know of that I
dream of having on this podcast one day
that you've cited in your work in this
book is phenomenal and at the very end
of the book you have some actionable
elements with this um yes wonderful
long-term relationship satisfaction
scale yes which means that you can turn
all the wisdom that you've heard on this
podcast today but also all the book all
the wisdom in these pages into something
actionable and this book is really
actionable that's one of the amazing
things about it you learn and you and
you know you go right back through the
research and the history of humans and
technology and Match.com and all of
those amazing things but you're left
with actionable advice on how to make
changes in your life um and key
takeaways as we see at the end of the
chapters what a wonderful timely book
what an important one because as often
as said the quality of Our Lives can be
determined by the quality of our
relationships and this is exactly what
this book Endeavors to do and does so
well yes so thank you Paul for gracing
our our show Once once again it's always
an honor I could speak to you for
[__] hours thank so we're gonna have
to do this again sometime but I I I deep
I deeply appreciate it it is an honor to
to be here and uh love the conversation
thank
you do you need a podcast to listen to
next we've discovered that people who
liked this episode also tend to
absolutely love another recent episode
we've done so I've linked that episode
in the description below I know you'll
enjoy
[Music]
it